[Musique]
mardi 23 janvier bonsoir et bienvenue
dans le 78 sur TV 78 tout de suite les
titres de cette
édition la disparition d'une figure de
la Résistance jeune vieve brousais est
décédée hier à l'âge de 97 ans celle que
l'on surnommait Tati à poissie était
engagée dans la vie associatif de
Saville pour laquelle elle a été
également mère adjointe le témoignage de
son neveu dans cette édition lire un
texte à haute voix face à un jury et un
public challenge plutôt difficile pour
un élève de CM1 CM2 mais une centaine de
jeunes franciliens a relevé le défi pour
les petits champion de la lecture la
finale école de ce concours se tenait il
y a quelques jours au château de
Versailles l'objectif donnerit le goût
de la lecture au plus petit de lecture
il en a été aussi question le weekend
dernier partout en France avec cet
événement les nuits de la la lecture
pour la 8e édition en pleine année des
Jeux Olympiques le corps était à
l'honneur reportage lors des animations
à la médiathèque du canal à Montini le
bretonneu et puis la suite de nos
interviews avec les maires de 50 ans en
Eveline dans l'invité du 78 en 2e partie
d'émission ils viennent en plateau tout
au long du mois de janvier et ce soir
nous recevons Alexandra Rosetti maire de
voisin le Bretonneux comme hier il
m'accompagne sur cette édition Nicolas
dandri bonsoir de la rédaction de tv78
on va faire le point tout de suite avec
vous sur les informations du jour
[Musique]
on débute donc avec cette disparition
celle de jeuneevev brousé c'était une
icône de la ville de poissie jeuneevève
Brousset est décédé ce lundi 22 janvier
à l'âge de 97 ans figure emblématique de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale cette pisiakz
s'était engagé à l'âge de 14 ans dans
des actes de résistance contre les
Allemands engagé dans la vie associative
de sa commune elle a aussi été adjointe
au maire de poissie pour rendre hommage
à jeune viève Rous nous avons contacté
son neveu qui a grandi à ses côtés on
l'écoute dans cette interview express
[Musique]
elle représente beaucoup de choses
presque tout elle m'a éevé 'a c'est elle
qui m'a appris à euh peut-être mon
métier
d'ambulancier à 3 ans elle m'emmenait
euh chercher les biberon à Versailles
dans dans son ambulance j'ai fait 43 ans
au SMUR de préine donc
voilà Tati c'était une française mais
une chrétienne
donc avec ma grand-mère et ben elles
sont elles ont été dans les dans les
maisons qui étaient vides pour récupérer
des des vêtements d'homme les amener à
la à l'église et là les prisonniers
changeaient et et pouvaent repartir
s'évader des prisons allemandes des du
prisonniers
allemand
[Musique]
au départ elle avait du mal à le
transmettre parce que malheureusement
son frère aîné lui n'est pasevenu des
concentrations il a été pendu à no GAM
je crois que c'était 8 f 8 février 45
elle entendait parler allemand elle
avait les poils qui sérissaient que ça
soit en primaire en
6e en 3e en seconde ou en même elle a
fait des classes de terminal ce qui
m'avait interloqué c'est que en fait les
questions que posait les enfants étaient
tous les mêmes vous avez connu général
de Gaulle ah et et et du coup vous avez
connu champ moulin bah oui j'ai connu
champ moulin j'ai connu général de Gaul
et vous avez connu et vous avez connu
Hitler et elle répondait ah ben non si
je l'avais connu jeurais jeis je
[Musique]
l'auraisigouillé voilà pour ce
témoignage après la disparition de
jeuneviè brouset figure de la résistante
de la résistance décédée hier à l'âge de
97 ans Nicolas direction la vallée de
Chevreuse à présent où le passage des
bus pose toujours question effectivement
grégoryi île-defance mobilité et
Transdev s'était engagé à un retour à la
normal et pour cause des perturbations
ont été constatées ce début janvier la
raison le changement d'opérateur de bus
en Vallée de Chevreuse qui a entraîné
une pénurie de main d'œuvre pourtant la
mairie de Chevreuse a publié hier un
appel à témoignage auprès des usagers
sur sa page facebook pour savoir s'il y
avait vraiment un retour à la normale et
cette publication qui a été aussi relayé
sur la page Facebook de Lévi saintnon
une autre commune qui avit touché par
cette perturbation des nouveaux noms
dévoilés pour les porteurs de la flamme
olympiqu dans les Yvelines et oui c'est
le conseil départemental des Yvelines
qui vient de dévoiler les noms de huit
porteurs de la flamme olympique le 23
juillet et la flamme paralympique qui
traversera les ivlines le 27 août ce
sont des ivlinoises et des ivlinois qui
sont engagés dans le monde associatif
alors sont pas tous tous les porteurs de
la de la flamme olympique et de la
flamme paralmpique parce qu'il y en a
une centaine mais il y en a il en a
certains qui sont donc dévoilés par et
qui ont été choisis par le Conseil
Départemental des iivlines on va les
voir s'afficher on retrouve notamment
Roger jckel porteur de la flamme
olympique des Jeux divers de Grenoble en
1968 et habitant de Saint-Germain en Laé
l'adolessente Manon chanceux de
Rambouillet et qui est passionnée par
les chevaux Jonathan Lefèvre joueur de
parentballe au Mureau anque vatrin 93
ans et engagé dans le monde associatif à
mantelaville Clémence de salever
multisport SP fait beaucoup de sport et
elle habite à saint-réi les chevreuses
et ensuite concernant la flamme
paralympique et bien ce il y a la
paracycliste sur route de 21 ans Jeanne
Le Pêcheur il y aura aussi Quentin
Boudeville qui est handballeur en
fauteuil à Oudan et alors vous avez vu
he en haut ce sont marqué c'était marqué
les éclaireurs parce que il faut
distinguer les porteurs dit officiels et
les éclaireurs qui je le rappelle ont
été choisis par le Conseil Départemental
des iines approche de ses Jeux
Olympiques et paralympiqu de par Paris
2024 du sport encore avec du football
vous nous parliez hier de ce match de
Versailles qui recevait martig dans le
cadre du championnat de National voilà
et puis bah c'est une nouvelle défaite
pour les Versaillais sur leur pelouse du
stade jamboin à Paris le FC Versailles s
incliné 1 à0 face à martig les
provençons ont ouvert le score à la 35e
minute et malgré beaucoup d'occasions
les hommes de la cité royale n'ont pas
réussi à les concrétiser il faut dire
quand même que le FC martig s'est
procuré aussi beaucoup d'occasion et a
plutôt dominé la rencontre au classement
Versailles et 12e du championnat qui
compte 18 équipes hein Grégory on va
voir le le classement s'afficher euh
donc c'est pas l'entièreté du classement
et donc Versailles 12e sur 18 et alors
pour rappel à la fin de la saison et
bien les Versaillais sont limit parce
que euh de la les équipes classées de la
13e à la 18e place seront relégué en
National 2 prochain rendez-vous pour les
ivelinois et bien c'est un déplacement à
Orléan ce vendredi 26 janvier et on
termine ces informations Nicolas avec de
la douceur direction la Bergerie
Nationale à Rambouillet et je sais que
vous aimez la douceur Grégory
effectivement la douceur des Olympiades
une série d'épreuves qui permet de
désigner le meilleur berger
d'Île-de-France 33 jeunes issus des
établissements agricoles de la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet et du lycée
agricole de la Bretonnière en Scine et
Marne ont participé à ses évaluations ce
mardi 23 janvier diagnostic médical des
brebises peser des agneaux ou encore
manucure des bêtes hein alors c'est pas
la même manicure que pour pour nous hein
les humains bien évidemment trouver le
reportage de la grande et Mathilde
Francou vous savez que Mathilde Francou
adore ce genre de reportage animalier ce
sera demain dans le 78 mercredi 24
janvier rendez-vous épris merci Nicolas
et comme d'habitude si vous aussi prêt
de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
evel n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news allez on ouvre une page dédiée
aux actualités
[Musique]
culturelles
chaque mardi maxense de la Crouée jeune
yvelinois passionné d'histoire vous en
apprend plus sur le département on vous
parlait tout à l'heure de la disparition
de la résistante jeunevève brouset et
bien ce soir Maxence revient sur un fait
malheureux survenu à la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale le massacre de
Chatou est l'un des derniers massacres
de la Seconde Guerre
[Musique]
mondiale il a eu lieu le 25 août 1944
même jour que la libération de Paris le
château de la pièce d'eau est situé à
Chatou et le 17 août les forces
française de l'Intérieur FFI parviennent
à le récupérer des mains de l'occupant
les résistants français décident alors
de laisser en captivité une quarantaine
de soldats allemands dans le garage de
la propriété mais ils sont rapidement
dénoncés par des collaborateurs français
auprès des Allemands rescapés le 24 août
les Français fêtaient l'arrivée de la
2uxe division blindée de Charles de
Gaulle pendant ce temps les Allemands
prenaient soin de miner tous les ponts
de l'Ouest parisien pour empêcher la
libération de Paris et le vendredi 25
août les unités allemandes prennent
violemment d'assaut le château de la
pièce d'eau ils oppressent les
résistants pour récupérer leurs
prisonniers le commandant Auguste torsa
est abattu et les FFI sont fait
prisonniers puis massacrés au total 27
hommes sont morts et la ville de Chatou
a décidé d'ériger un monument à leur
hommage le 11 juin
1950 donne au plus jeune le goût du
livre depuis 2012 le concours des petits
champions de la lecture permet à des
enfants en classe de CM1 CM2 de se
défier au travers de toute la France le
principe lire à haute voie l'extrait
d'un livre de leur choix et ce pendant 3
minutes face à un jury le château de
Versailles a accueilli une centaine de
jeunes pour la première étape de ce
concours c'était il y a quelques jours
le reportage de Julien
Leroi imagine que tu prennes une
fourchette et que tu l'enfonces dans ta
Mar et que tu commences à tomber au fond
de ta boîte cranienne c'est le grand
moment pour Salma 3 minutes pour
convaincre un jury en lisant un extrait
du livre de son choix pour elle ce sera
mortel adelle écrit par Antoine Dole et
Diane lefeilleur l'histoire d'une
fillette au fort caractère décidé à
mener la vie du à ses proches un roman
amusant que Salma a voulu partager avec
ses camarades pour le concours des
petits champions de la lecture je
trouvais que l'extrait que j'ai pris bah
il était très drôle et bah d'ailleurs ça
a été le cas vu que la première fois que
j'ai lu il y en a qui ont
rigolé du coup bah ça m'a fait plaisir
moi j'espère déjà que je vais réussir à
me qualifier et après toujours viser
plus haut ce jeudi 18 janvier une
centaine d'enfants venus de H8 classes
franciliennes disputer la finale école
au château de Versailles une première
étape de sélection pour pour ce grand
jeu de lecture à voix haute proposé aux
élèves de CM1 CM2 éloquence posture et
transmission des émotions du texte étit
scruté par les membres du jury
l'objectif donner le goût de la lecture
dès le plus
jeuneur souvent le fait de lire à voix
haute pour un public créer un déclic
chez des enfants qui sont pas forcément
encore lecteurs ça leur donne envie de
lire de de pouvoir réaliser cette
lecture devant les autres d'être aussi
évalué par les autres dans la classe
parce qu'il se donnent des conseils
entre eux j'aime beaucoup lire et
j'aimerais montrer à tout le monde que
je sais bien lire grâce au micro bah je
sentais mon cœur battre et il btait
assez vite mais quand j'ai terminé ma
lecture je me sentais beaucoup mieux
donc on a fait beaucoup de plaisir et il
s'agit donc de
Salma un nouveau chapitre débute pour la
jeune Salma gagnante de sa classe le
mois prochain elle disputera l'étape
départementale avant peut-être de
concourir à la finale nationale à la
Comédie Française à Paris dans les
Yvelines 176 classes participent à cette
11e édition des petits champions de la
lecture bravo à Salma et à tous les
participants le livre qui était aussi à
l'honneur le weekend dernier avec la 8e
édition des Nuits de la lecture à cette
occasion la médiathèque du canal à
Montini lebretenux a ouvert le ses
portes le temps d'une soirée au
programme compte ou encore flash mob sur
le thème du corps un clin d'œil pour les
Jeux Olympiques Gabriel Gontier et
Julien
Leroi
que tu as de grands yeux
Papou c'est pour mieux te
voir dis la grosse voix sous la couette
des nuits dédiées à la lecture et aux
activités culturelles cette année encore
les nuits de la lecture ont fait leur
grand retour organisé par le Centre
national du livre cet événement est
devenu un rendez-vous phare des
médiathèques du territoire pour nous
maintenant oui c'est devenu un
rendez-vous incontournable toute
l'équipe a plaisir à travailler sur ce
rendez-vous les publics sont là et nous
demande ce qu'on va faire et puis
répondre vraiment présent aux activités
qu'on leur propose le thème choisi pour
cette édition 2024 le corps clin d'œil
aux Jeux Olympiques il a donc fallu
choisir des œuvres où cette thématique
est abordée alors les amis c'est qui le
plus grand demande que le cochon
l'objectif de cet événement inculquer le
goût de lire aux petits et au grands ça
me permet à les sensibiliser à la
lecture et les racontines ça permet ça
aide à ce que les enfants écoutent parce
que nous on raconte pas forcément les
histoires de la même manière que que les
personnes qui le font et ben tous les
soirs avec ma petite fille on fait quoi
le soir on on lit les histoires tu aimes
bien lire oui c'est important pour toi
oui en plus de la lecture pour honorer
la thématique du corps et du mouvement
un grand flash mob sur l'aair d' School
Musical a clôturé la soirée une façon de
rendre l'événement à la fois culturel et
[Musique]
festif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toujours à Montini le Bretonneux le 6
février prochain la salle Jacques Brel
accueille le Cabaret des frissons
garantis un spectacle qui mèle textes
chansons et même des tours de magie
autour du thème de la nourriture voici
trois raisons de ne pas louper cette
programmation c'est au micro de Mathilde
Francou bonjour je me présente José
Cachin mère adjoint délégué à la culture
et à l'événemen cel à montinil
Bretonneux et si je suis présent devant
en vous cher public c'est simplement
pour vous donner l'envie et vous donner
surtout trois bonnes raisons d'aller
assister au spectacle Le Cabaret des
frissons
[Musique]
garanties la première raison c'est tout
simplement l'occasion comme je le disais
d'assister à un spectacle qui s'est mêlé
à la fois théâtre magie et chanson et
tout cela en parlant de mille le fromage
et les boîtes la confiture et les
cornichons laarde et leur la mayonnaise
et les
cornichons la seconde raison c'est que
si vous avez la chance de faire partie
du public vous aurez peut-être une
seconde chance c'est celle tout
simplement de vous faire inviter sur
scène pour danser un slow et enfin la
dernière raison c'est que le théâtre de
cristal est une troupe inclusive qui
associe indistinctement des comédiens et
des comédiennes en situation de handicap
pour faire ce tour j'ai besoin d'une
bonne table un verre une bouteille et de
tubes je vais faire passer le verre à la
place de la bouteille et la bouteille à
la place du
verre et voilà le travail si vous voulez
qu'on boit un coup ensemble il faut de
verre et de
bouteill à la petite soif à la grande
soif
s alors si ces trois raisons vous ont
convaincu vous êtes invité à venir
assister au Cabaret des frissons
garantis qui se déroulera le mardi 6
février à 20h30 à la salle jacqubrelle
de montinil
Bretonneau avant l'invité du 78 on
regarde les prévisions météo de
demain pluie et grisaille au menu de
votre journée de mercredi dit dans les
ivelines le matin les températures sont
tout de même plutôt douces avec 12°grés
sur l'ensemble du territoire
l'après-midi la pluie persistera dans le
secteur de Man de Mantel jolie mais
cessera du dans le reste des zivelines
côté température compté 13° ce mercredi
24 janvier c'est là Saint-François de
salle tout de suite l'invité du
[Musique]
l'année 2024 à 50 ans ieline tout au
long du mois de janvier les maires de
l'agglomération viennent en plateau pour
parler des grands projet dans leur
commune ce soir c'est Alexandra Rosetti
qui est avec nous bonsoir maire de la
commune de voisin lebretonneux également
vice-présidente de 50 ans en Yveline
délégué au développement économique et à
l'attractivité du territoire tout
d'abord bonne année à vous et à toutes
les vinoises et tous les Vinois
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de l'année
2023 à voisin alors ça a été une année
très intense etès très riche avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de projets qui sont
arrivés aussi à terme et puis un gros
gros travail de concertation qu'on
évoquera sans doute après donc ça a été
une année pour moi vraiment intense
euh et qui qui produit des résultats
maintenant donc voilà une belle année
donc avec des des projets qu'on va
peut-être voir aboutir cette année on va
en parler effectivement dans cet
entretien et cette année 2024 vous
l'abordez comment alors c'est une année
qu'on attend tous ici mais j'imagine que
vous l'attendez aussi cette année
olympique 50 ans va accueillir de
nombreuses épreuves de Paris 2024 et
d'ailleurs la commune a un labelle terre
de jeu comment vous abordez cette
échéance alors on est on est ravi alors
bien sûr les épreuves ne vont pas se
dérouler à voisin mais quand même très
très proche donc nous sommes centre de
préparation des jeux pour le tennis de
table et ben j'espère bien pouvoir
accueillir je pense ça commence à venir
des équipes internationales pour venir
jouer donc s'entraîner au tennis de
table on a déjà eu l'équipe de France
qui est venue s'entraîner sur notre
bicross notre BMX tout neu de de la
remise euh donc voilà donc nous on
espère on veut en faire une fête en tout
cas pour nos habitants et on réfléchit à
des des petits événements voilà des
expositions des pour pour que tout le
monde se sente associé et un esprit très
sportif cette année on parl du tennis de
table on suit régulièrement le club de
voisin bretonux qui organise en plus un
grand tournoi de tennis de table en dis
sport maintenant qui se déroule au au
Vélodrome national et qui se déroulera à
voisin cette année et qui se déroulera à
voisin cette année voilà petit scoup
tout première fois voilà dans les grands
dossiers 2024 il y a forcément aussi la
la fin des travaux de cet écoquartier
parc du lac situé sur le terrain dit de
la remise alors on est entre la RD36 et
le quartier du Lac en entrée de ville
pour rappeler quelques grands axes du
projet il prévoit 500 logement de
nouveaux commerces et services la
nouvelle aussi église du secteur on va
avoir les premières livraisons cette
année c'est bien ça voilà bah l'idée
c'était que tout le quartier soit livré
la même année d'abord pour Al ça a été
un vrai défi pour les constructeurs he
parce qu'il a fallu fallu faire sortir
tous ces bâtiments de terre en même
temps donc ça donne une impression un
petit peu curieuse de de densité mais
d'abord c'est un projet qui date d' y a
15 20 ans faut dire et puis l'idée
c'était d'abord de d'essayer d'apporter
le moins de nuisance possible au
riverins donc que les travaux durent le
moins longtemps possible et puis ben
voilà comme ça nous accueillerons tous
les logements en même temps ça va
s'étaler on va dire du mois d'avril je
pense jusqu'à la fin de l'année et je
disais de nouveaux services qui verront
le jour dans ce cet écoquartier et
notamment une crèche c'est un projet
nécessaire pour les habitants qui est ce
service pour pour ces habitants bah oui
parce que des nouveaux logements génèent
de nouveaux besoins en terme de de
berceau comme on dit donc j'ai une
crèche qui est quand même ancienne et
puis en très très bon état donc c'était
l'occasion de de faire une crèche neuve
avec toutes les dernières normes les
mêmes chauffé à la géothermie nous y
ajoindrons le notre relais d'assistante
maternelle hein qui existe déjà dans un
autre lieu de la ville et puis à l'étage
une salle pour le quartier parce que le
quartier du Lac n'a pas de salle ni de
maison ni de salle de quartier donc
c'était l'occasion d'avoir un bâtiment
vraiment neuf qui réponde à plusieurs
besoins en même temps combien de bceau
du coup dans la crèche une soixantaine
une soixantaine de de berceaux dans
cette crèche qui verra donc le jour dans
ce quartier parc du lac alors en 2023 le
groupe scolaire du bois de la Garen a
définitivement fermé ses portes dans la
ville mais justement vous souhaitez lui
donner un avenir à ce site alors
plusieurs ateliers ont eu lieu dans le
courant de l'année passée avec les
habitants pour recueillir leurs idées
répondre aussi à certaines de leurs
interrogations est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
sait ce que va devenir cet ancien groupe
scolaire alors la concertation a abouti
à à des des tas d'idées à des
propositions bon tout peut pas toujours
être retenu mais globalement le souhait
c'était de faire des logements plutôt à
destination des seniors de l'habitat
comme on dit inclusif c'est-à-dire avec
des lieux de vie partagés qui puissent
aussi bénéficier d'ailleurs au reste du
quartier donc à partir de ce que les
habitants ont pu dire ben nous avons
bâti un un cahier des charges que nous
avons ont transmis à à des promoteurs
qui sont en train de travailler et qui
vont rendre leur copie si je puis dire
début février et puis ensuite on on aura
d'autres temps d'échange avec les
habitants
euh je sais qu'il y a des habitants qui
vous souhaiteraient qui préféreraient
garder le bâtiment le problème c'est que
le bâtiment est très grand je n'ai pas
d'usage à lui donner parce que j'ai déjà
deux équipements publics dans ce
quartier et euh voilà l'entretien la
rénovation serait au-dessus de nos
moyens alors que nous n'avons pas
d'utilisation particulière à lui don
donc on aura du nouveau cette année hein
c'est ce que voilà comme ça l'idée c'est
vraiment de savoir où on va même si ça
démarre les travaux vont pas démarrer
dans dans les de mois qui viennent
évidemment mais je pense c'est important
que les habitants sachent ce qu'il y
aura à la place de de cette école alors
un autre projet on en parlait déjà dans
les enjeux des dernières élections
municipales à voisin en 2020 c'est la
création d'un nouveau cimetière de 600
places en lieu et place du stade du
champ du loup alors ce cimetière
s'appellera le cimetière du Saut du Loup
car le cimetière principal arrive à à
saturation où est-ce qu'on en est
concrètement est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'il
pourrait aboutir ce ce projet dès 2024
ah oui il faut qu'il aboutisse en 2024
donc là les travaux sont arrêtés parce
qu'il y a les intempéries la neige la
pluie et cetera euh dès dès que c'est
possible ça reprend pour nous on
aimerait bien une livraison euh fin de
l'été on va dire et puis voilà c'est un
dossier qui a été très long parce que
euh ça nécessite des études de sol et
euh ça nécessite d'être conforme à la
loi sur l'eau et à voisin bah c'est pas
évident de trouver un endroit où il y a
pas de humide pas de nappe fratique euh
donc là on a on avait juste ce petit
créneau là j'ai envie de dire sur le
terrain de rugby mais mais le terrain de
rugby lui-même est entouré de de zone
humide donc un un projet qui va voir le
jour en 2024 et dans les travaux
programmés il y a aussi alors ils sont
arrivés à échéance c'est le le
réaménagement du stade du Grand Prix il
y a des terrains de tennis des cours de
paddle qui sont désormais donc
disponibles pour les habitants c'est
bien ça tout à fait alors il y a il y a
plusieurs choses il y a pour un espace
pour la pétanque avec un un lieu de
convivialité qui était très attendu par
nos joueurs de pétanque deux terrains de
padel couvert comme ça comme on est
quand même dans un pays où il y a
quelques Anton Paris il est utilisé
vraiment tout le temps et puis on a
refait on a fait un terrain de tennis en
qure temps comment ils appellent ça en
terre battu si vous voulez et un autre
terrain de tennis pour qui lui est
complètement ouvert à tous les vissinois
euh gratuitement donc ça aujourd'hui
c'est ouvert pour les habitant c'est
ouvert c'est en marche et vraiment euh
c'est tout le temps ple alors une
initiative originale que dont on va
parler avec vous c'est donc pour
promouvoir le le bénévolat auprès des
jeunes vcinois et bien la ville va a
décidé de les attirer en les rémunérant
avec une monnaie virtuelle vous avez
créé une monnaie virtuelle
expliquez-nous ce projet alors c'est
vrai qu'on est un peu dans le monde des
blockchain et cetera donc l'idée c'est
aussi de les sensibiliser à à au danger
aussi de la la monnaie virtuel et donc
en échange d'heur de bénévolat pour des
associations on les rémunérerit donc en
en monnaie virtuelle en Civic comme ça
qu'on va l'appeler et puis en échange et
bien ils peuvent ils pourront avoir
accès à des spectacles gratuits ou avoir
des réductions chez les commerçants qui
voudront bien être partenair de cette
opération vous avez une idée du nom de
cette monnaie virtuelle encore le Civic
vous l'avez dit donc pour cette monnaie
virtuelle à à voisin le Breton et on
sait contexte difficile pour toutes les
communes hein ça c'est vrai pour toutes
les communes de France qui ont de moins
en moins de recettes alors pour
maintenir aussi un un certainau un
niveau d'investissement euh aussi
financer tous ces projets dont on vient
parler est-ce que vous refusez ou pas le
le levier des impôts locaux est-ce que
vous pourriez activer ce levier à voisin
pour peut-être financer ces mesures
alors là pas cette année puisqu'on l'a
fait en 2023 et de façon quand même
assez importante parce que nous n'avions
plus rien c'est-à-dire ce qu'on appelle
la dotation globale de fonctionnement de
l'État est tombée à zéro et nous sommes
la seule commune de Saint-Quentin à être
à zéro quand même euh et quand toutes
les ressources S menuisent on a beau
aller chercher on va chercher beaucoup
beaucoup de subventions et vraiment je
remercie nos partenaires que sont
SaintQuentin la Région le Département
parce que sans eux bah il y a beaucoup
de choses qui se feraient pas euh et là
cette année non non non ne touchera pas
les impôts on va même essayer d'amorcer
une petite baisse quand même parce qu'il
fallait qu'on passe un cap difficile
l'an dernier avec l'inflation évidemment
et puis bon le coût de l'énergie qui qui
s'est envolé voilà il y a un moment
c'est des choses qu'on ne peut pas
anticiper pour le coup et nous avons dû
faire appel à la solidarité des
propriétaire puisqu'il n'y a plus de
taxe d'habitation alors deux choses pour
terminer Alexandra Rosetti il y a un
anniversaire qui va être célébré cette
année comme dans d'autres communes c'est
la libération de de la ville en
1944 et des festivités sont prévues à
voisin Bretonneux absolument on voudrait
vraiment marquer ce moment-là c'est une
commémoration qu'on fait bien sûr tous
les ans et qui a beaucoup de sens pour
nous donc on toute l'année va être
jalonné on a déjà commencé avec une une
conférence il y en aura d'autres plus on
va emmener nos jeunes nos seniors
voir les plages du débarquement on fait
des propositions à nos écoles aussi pour
qu'elles puissent sintégrer alors le
problème c'est que c'est le 24 août donc
souvent les gens sont quand même encore
en vacances mais malgré tout on aura des
on aura des véhicules d'époque également
que que l'univem va mettre à notre
disposition voilà on voudrait vraiment
faire un événement marquant pour
terminer cet entretien on vous donne une
carte blanche vous avez une minute pour
aborder un sujet de votre choix qui qui
vous tient à cœur c'est à vous alors le
sujet qui me tient à cœur c'est euh là
ce qu'on appelle la Vada voisin ville
ami des aînés puisque nous nous sommes
inscrits dans dans cette démarche qui
est une démarche qui va nous permettre
de de de mieux cerner les besoins de nos
seiors on sait que c'est un enjeu alors
partout en France évidemment à voisin
23,5i % des habitants sont âgés de plus
de 60 ans et puis il y en a aussi
beaucoup qui situent dans la tranche
d'âge 60 74 ans et la tranche qui
augmente c'est aussi la tranche au-delà
des des 75 ans donc c'est un enjeu pour
préserver l'autonomie c'est c'est un
enjeu à beaucoup de niveau euh et donc
nous lançons un travail et donc j'invite
les les seigneors de voisins qui le
souhaitent le 9 février l'après-midi à
venir participer à un café rencontre où
on voudrait bah les écouter sur beaucoup
de thématiques ça va de l'information
les déplacements l'environnement ça peut
être le parcours résidentiel aussi vous
voyez au bois de la Garenne c'est pas un
hasard si si cette idée est sortie de là
je crois qu'il faut que nos seniors
soient heureux de rester à voisin et
être vile amie des aînés c'est aussi
être vileamie de tout le monde parce que
ce qu'on fait pour faciliter la vie de
nos aînés ben en fait c'est utile à tous
les habitants merci d'avoir été avec
nous Alexandra Rosetti maire de la
commune de voisin le bretonau une
nouvelle fois bonne année à vous et à
tous vos habitants merci beaucoup voilà
c'est la fin du 78 merci de votre
fidélité demain vous avez rendez-vous
avec une nouvelle édition et c'est
Mathilde Francou qui sera à la
présentation belle soirée sur
tv78
[Musique]